bonsoir le one benjamin biolay bravo
magnifique prestation tous les deux très
belles rencontres aussi peut-être qu'on
peut justement avoir un petit mot sur
votre rencontre déjà votre réaction luan
lorsqu'on vous a proposé ce duo moi j'ai
tout de suite dit oui on sait très
impressionnant de chanter avec avec quoi
en fait mais mais c'était une superbe
expérience je suis super contente merci
ben moi pareil quand on m'a proposé de
chanter avec loane j'étais juste savoir
si nombreuses et cette chanson est
vraiment
va tellement bien mais c'est la chanson
de circonstance à cannes 70ème
anniversaire s'il en est je pense pas
qu'on ait beaucoup peu tendu avant avant
cette non non non c'est tendu comme des
strings évidemment ce nom c'est très
impressionnant franchement c'est après
on s'est dit la même chose
ah oui on s'est dit la même chose on
était un genre ça va ça va et toi oui ça
va et après bon en vrai ça allait pas
d'accord franchement c'est un public
compliqué il faut pas il faut faut être
un peu égoïste il faut concéder un but à
ce qu'on veut à fait rationnel la note
publiée dans les personnages qui moi je
pensais plus tectoniques arômes et celle
de grands etc
et puis les gens qui sont derrière leur
écran bref jeter à l'eau si on se met à
penser c'est pas possible en fait le
chanteur chanteuse acteurs actrices
nan nan mais aussi donc c'est vrai que
de vous avoir tous les deux c'était
exceptionnel ce soir justement alors
évidemment on est dans la chanson mais
on pense on a devant des plus grands
réalisateurs du monde pedro almodovar
qui peut avoir un oeil de réalisateurs
tu vois ce que je veux dire donc un
moment où si on se voit acteurs aussi en
train de chanter
non ce serait ridicule
j'ai envie que tu trouves la chanson
magnifique je me demande si je la
connais peut-être le très francophile
mais se met dans sept jours de
perspectives on oublié et la mise en
scène va être parfaite c'est exact et
factor attention bianca de ne pas tomber
je vais peut-être aller j'ai peut-être
aller les départs dont voilà non
attention voilà donc tu n'es pas bien
qu'à tomber dans les marches
bah oui plusieurs fois arrivé il ya eu
tellement de choses bien mais tu seras
pas la première on parle et d'émotion à
l'instant avec jamal one il y avait
beaucoup d'émotion bianca sur cette
scène face à pedro tout à l'heure ah oui
au moins pour moi vraiment la famille
qui est avec qui j'ai de la ciotat
particulier j'aime beaucoup et c'était
un sou puisque et que je voulais le
faire aujourd'hui on en sont un peu pour
lui bon pour tout le monde aussi mais un
ticket de mon corps était pour lui
qu'est ce que ça représente le festival
de cannes pour tous les trois mois
c'était ma première fois à vrai dire
donc c'est très très impressionnant
s'est c'est un énorme festival et c'est
quelque chose de mondial donc c'est
assez assez étonnant j'avoue que j'étais
très stressée mais mais ça représente
pour moi toute la magie du cinéma quand
je vois moi j'ai déjà venus quelquefois
mais c'est toujours aussi impressionnant
et délicieux et glamour se commet une
parenthèse dans la vie quoi on aura
moins biais comme ça et puis je pense
toujours à l'histoire de ce cinéma de ce
festival la survie s'est passé tellement
de choses extraordinaires des choses
curieuses des choses grandioses des
choses tellement de films inoubliables
son ont été projetés ici pour la
première phase quand même et puis on a
eu bien qu'alliés en plus je pense
aujourd'hui vous revenez avec le soleil
le ciel bleu c'est quand même super
cannes non c'est un festival c'est parce
que c'est aussi ça ce qu'est avec 7
soleils
on sait
imaginez les deux bouts d'ailés festival
quand on voit tout le photobook et
c'était tout son bikini à la plage très
j'ai passé beaucoup aujourd'hui je vis
70 sont des gens qui viennent de cette
ville qui s'éveille
qui sait mais dans cette soleil avec des
jolies robes c'est magnifique c'est
magique c'est magique avec alors on va
rappeler un président espagnol pedro
almodovar avec une maîtresse de
cérémonie italienne monica bellucci
c'est vrai que le cinéma monica l'a
rappelé à l'instant il n'y a pas de
frontières n'y a pas de sexe ya pas de
drapeau voudrait qu'on l'a on la
réécoute c'était monica bellucci à
l'instant à l'intérieur du palais des
festivals écoutez les cinémas puise sa
source dans le mélange des forces
complémentaires et contradictoires c'est
pour ça que l'identité du cinéma laly
sexe qui drape aux frontières sublime
maîtresse de cérémonie qui a vraiment
une très belle histoire aussi avec le
festival c'est bien le rappeler oui et
monica elle a tout vécu à cannes elle a
vécu son scandale avec suivre exactement
voilà exactement c'est vrai que jury et
ses maîtresses de cérémonie pour la
seconde fois et elle représente très
très très bien ce festival on va
rappeler et luan aussi que tu seras
bientôt au cinéma à nouveau nos
patriotes très très belle expérience
aussi film d'époque ce que tu veux juste
nous en dire un petit mot jeu c'est un
film qui sort le 14 juin ans s'appelle
no patriots et de gabriel le bomin et
comme tu l'as bien 17 ans film d'époque
sur la seconde guerre mondiale et je
vais pas en dire plus mais j'ai vraiment
vraiment être des pauvres en parler
puisque bientôt et benjamin la sortie
d'un nouvel album qui s'appelle wolberg
qui s'appelle relevé qui sort vendredi
je crois c'est un hasard c'est un
hommage à carlos gardel
donc c'est pas vraiment un hasard mais
c'est un hasard je savais pas par
exemple tout ça arriverait et bien un
film aussi de manuel fin qui s'appelle
la douleur qui sortira bientôt
d'après duras est jamais venu la tenue
marshall qui s'appelle numéro in voilà
merci à tous et blanc' et on vous
retrouvera bientôt sur scène au théâtre
national de chaillot ma nouvelle pièce
au septembre merci à tous les noirs ou
libérer merci infiniment d'être venu en
direct merci merci beaucoup et puis mon
festival si vous restez un petit peu
attention assez bien comme happening
c'est parfait en plus c'est raccord
kacou leur démarche attention pas tomber
oui merci c'était magnifique
voilà on était avec blanca li on va
maintenant enchaîner on va retrouver
pedro almodovar